MARK MIRCHANDANI:
For many Cloud users,
billing is just
something you deal
with at the end of the month.
But for larger teams
and organizations,
you'll hit a scale
at which it becomes
critical to understand
costs and to manage
what you're paying for.
On this episode of
"Beyond Your Bill,"
we'll go into more depth
on billing accounts,
the payments profile, and
managing billing permissions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the last video, we
looked at an overview of how
GCP resources are organized.
In order to make sure
those resources are
paid for correctly, the billing
account and payments profile
need to be set up with
the right permissions.
See, some GCP services
have free tiers.
But you won't be able
to go beyond that tier
without having to wait
to pay for all the usage.
All services need to exist
as part of a project.
And each project will need
to have a single billing
account associated with it,
though a billing account can
have multiple
associated projects.
And the billing
reports and invoice
will be able to break
down costs by project.
Billing accounts will
also be directly linked
to a Google payments profile,
which sits outside the Cloud
and is used to pay for
all Google services,
like G Suite and Google Ads.
If Google Cloud Platform is the
only Google service you use,
you may not interact much
with the payments profile.
However, it's important to keep
track of both billing accounts
and payments
profiles, especially
for larger organizations using
multiple products and services.
For GCP, think of
the billing account
as the way to organize all
your Cloud-specific billing,
and the payments profile for
how to actually pay and view
invoices.
Both have their own
sets of permissions,
so you can control who
can view and manage
the different accounts.
We recommend setting up multiple
administrators for each of them
to safeguard against any issues
and to review them regularly.
It could even end up being
the same admins for both.
It's also a good idea to
only have a single billing
account and a single
payments profile
to help make it
easier to manage them.
Having multiple can make cost
management complicated down
the road.
So stick to as few as possible.
Let's look at setting up and
managing an online billing
account, which is paid with a
credit card or a bank account.
As your company
grows, you'll want
to work with the GCP Sales team
to set up an offline billing
account, which is
paid with invoices.
Either way, you need to be able
to manage your billing account
permissions through the GCP
Console and the payments
profile online.
In the console, you can
open up the left navigation
and choose Billing to see
your current billing accounts.
You may need to click on
Manage Billing Accounts
to get to the right page.
And then click on
Create Account.
Choose a descriptive name
for the billing account,
and choose a location, which
determines the currency.
Each billing account
and related invoice
can only represent
a single currency.
You'll then need to set
up the payments profile
and can choose between
individual and business.
This can't be changed later.
You'll also be able to choose
the primary contact, who
will be the administrator
for the payments profile.
Again, we recommend
setting up multiple admins
or using a group to ensure a
reasonable level of redundancy.
The payments profile will
need a form of payment,
such as a credit card
or a bank account.
For more redundancy, you
should actually come back later
and add an additional form
of payment as a backup,
as well as reviewing
your administrators
and your notification settings.
Once the new billing
account is created,
or if you're working with
an existing billing account,
you'll be able to manage it
from the right side, or the Info
panel.
The best thing to
start with is to add
an additional administrator.
You can do this by clicking
the Add Members button.
You can add individual
users this way,
or you can add a group.
So there won't be
any access concerns
when you need to find the
billing account admin.
In addition, you can also add
billing account viewers, who
have view-only
access to information
like how much each project
associated with this billing
account costs, as well as
billing account users, who
can not only view the details,
but also associate projects
with this billing account.
Once you've set
up your users, you
can then create new projects,
or take existing projects
and associate them with
this billing account.
Similar to billing
accounts, you can
manage permissions for
projects and folders
by adding users and
assigning roles.
You can even create
your own custom roles
and choose the exact
breakdown of permissions
that a user can have.
Giving a user view
access to a project
will let them see costs only
for that project, as opposed
to a billing account
viewer, who can see costs
for all projects associated
with that billing account.
If you need to change
information about the payments
profile, you'll do that
from payments.google.com,
rather than the GCP console.
As I've mentioned,
it's critical to make
sure to review the users and
permissions on both billing
accounts and payments
profile regularly, perhaps
every quarter, and to make
sure that your team knows
who the administrators are.
In case of any
issues, you'll want
to contact the billing
account administrators
and have them reach out to
Billing Support as needed.
With that set up,
you can now make sure
any GCP services are
paid for correctly,
and that your organization
is set up to manage costs.
Check out the links for a deeper
dive and more best practices
around managing your billing
account and payments profile.
In the next video,
we'll look at how
to directly examine
your costs using billing
reports in the GCP console.
[MUSIC PLAYING]